so uh
i was thinking it would be fun to to
come here come back to stanford
my alma mater and just tell a few of the
stories
um basically the path that uh
that led from really where you all are
sitting right now to the the stage up
here and
palantir and all the uh the other things
have happened in the last eight years
so uh firstly how many
grad students do we have in the room
okay and how many undergrads
all right and of the undergrads how many
uh how many sleek hits do we have in
here
do we have any sleek kids
okay that's that's actually kind of
funny unto itself because i was going to
start the story with the story of slee
my uh my beginning i i was a sleek kid
my beginning here at stanford
um it's actually pretty funny there
there aren't aren't too many in here
so i was fortunate enough to
um grow up around here in fremont and
during high school
i don't want to date myself here too
much but i uh
i worked on an online gradebook software
company
um during the first.com bubble and so in
those kind of
formative adolescent years was able to
jump outside of the kind of
narrow high school bubble and see a bit
about how the world worked in the world
of entrepreneurship
you can probably uh take a few guesses
at how much i knew about what i was
doing that i was attacking k to 12 when
still being in k
to 12 and education isn't exactly the
most lucrative market
although it's gotten a lot better since
then but it was
very helpful to get to kind of see
things from an outside perspective see
what actually worked what didn't work
uh i snuck in here went to a few
lectures at stanford
basis had a business plan competition i
jumped into that
and i don't think i ever won a single
business plan competition
i learned i learned business plans are
not my forte
but i also learned that stanford had the
most
intense concentration of traditional
talent i'd ever seen anywhere
and there's a special energy this
aliveness to everyone here and this this
openness towards the world that
i was so excited about being a part of
and my number one
uh the consuming desire was to take the
talent here
and to just work on changing the world
on transforming things
and so you know those those first few
weeks freshman year always daunting
show up there in the slee dorms in uh
florence moore uh
was in faison and uh
you talk to the kids and they're just as
brilliant as you imagined
and traditional talent is just
overwhelming how much is there
but the uh i had
i had this nagging feeling um
whereas the traditional iq was
incredibly high and incredibly
concentrated
what i was really looking for was this
type of worldly wisdom about how to take
the world of ideas and actually connect
it to the real world
they actually generate an impact with
all this and this is what draws so many
of us here to stanford in the first
place
and i was struck by uh how little of
that knowledge kind of existed within
the institutions
you know i've learned since then that so
much of entrepreneurship simply can't be
taught we we have
formats like this and i think they're
fantastic for sharing a little bit that
can be shared
um so much of it just has to be learned
through experience
but this kind of recognition that there
is a difference between traditional iq
and the uh kind of entrepreneurial
disruptive force
and that that latter category needs to
be learned
outside the traditional balance of
institutions like stanford
it was a very important starting point
for just how i went about doing things
here and
hopefully um hopefully that that may
help inform how uh how you do some of
this stuff
so kind of recognizing there was no
single linear path that would lead to an
entrepreneurial outcome i immediately
tried to jump to non-linear paths
uh which for me meant working on
products i love working on products
of course since my last one was a k-12
grade book i don't exactly know if my
choice of product at this age was
particularly great um but i had some fun
ones in those opening years
i uh this was the beginning of wireless
internet taking over
everyone had these routers no one had
any idea where to place them
so i had this idea that i would hack the
network card in my laptop
and i got this old crusty cart from my
house in fremont
uh i got i played on the
varsity tennis team in high school and i
got an old tennis container and a tennis
ball
put a laser mouse on top of it so i
could track 2d coordinates with this
cart
and then i hacked into the driver in
this laptop so i could pull out the
signal strength readouts
and effectively build a 2d topological
model of the signal strength in a room
like this
now what did this actually uh amount to
well i was this freshman a few months
into stanford and i've got this cart
that's roughly
sized like this and i'm walking all
around tresseter and everywhere else
with this tennis ball duct tape
contraption
in rows probably looking like a crazy
person just uh back and forth mapping
out all this uh this signal
obviously that idea didn't exactly
evolve into palantir
but yeah you know after that i started
working on an augmented reality
toolkit it was actually part of my
senior project work
and what it did was it would take
webcams
and it would find these these uh
elements in a scene and basically
project a 3d matrix onto that so it
could determine
the 3d coordinates of what it was seeing
uh anyways
you could rig this thing up to build a
3d mouse so i wrote a 3d mouse
i connected it to quake 2 which was just
recently open sourced
and uh there you there you have it
you know you have uh this this new way
of interacting
with video games with your computer you
can just move around and move your hands
to
to do things kind of minority report-ish
and i figured that this could be
next big thing and i talked to a good
venture capitalist friend of mine
ashmitsudana who i think now is a
partner at foundation capital
and he said stefan it's a great idea but
it can't impact the real world
the entrenched players in this market
these console manufacturers they're the
ones who control the distribution and
because of this uh essential feature of
the marketplace
it might be a good product it might be a
good idea but it
probably won't be a reality and so of
course this like really bummed me out
this is not this is not what you want to
hear here and any entrepreneur has
plenty of stories like this where they
they get the bad news
but sure enough years later how many you
all have used to connect before
right you've probably played with
playstation 3 as variant of it you know
we got that exact same technology and
sure enough it came from the console
manufacturers who
who controlled most of it so he was
right but
my uh the story i'm trying to paint here
is one of working outside the
traditional bounds of the institution
here at stanford while still leveraging
um the resources that were available and
uh still longing to find the way of
connecting that world of ideas and
products to the actual real world
uh the next kind of story in this
adventure was
uh doing research with andrew eng
jumping in and learning as much about ai
as possible
how many computer scientists in the room
could you raise your hands
so what is this like 15 maybe 10 percent
so the computer scientists here can
particularly appreciate this you know i
grew up
watching star trek next generation we've
got commander data
we have artificial intelligence in the
ship's computer it's everywhere and it's
um this this incredibly powerful idea
that computers
will eventually catch up with
generalized human intelligence
and so uh as a computer scientist when
you first start learning about modern ai
statistical machine learning at least
for me
the very first thing you notice is this
stuff is very very hard
anyone who's taken cs229 uh knows knows
that feeling in particular
um andrewing is the best teacher for it
highly recommend doing anything you can
with that guy
uh he's he's great and
uh as i as i learned ais i
tried to mind that treasure chest to
find something an idea so powerful that
it could
punctuate from that world and transcend
into ours and have it have a big impact
um i uh
i had the same kind of nagging sensation
i had
that freshman year in sleep that these
kids despite being really smart they
there's there's something that may be
missing
and with the ai research
i think modern artificial intelligence
is uh
it has these brilliant elegant models uh
these kind of topological visual
uh analogy models for how to do
classification how to divide up problems
but they're incredibly quantitative and
they tend to deal with problems that
have a very well-defined structure
and there are some very clever
algorithms and there's been a lot of
clever
algorithmic breakthroughs i think in the
last 15 years
but the nagging sensation that i
ultimately couldn't kick is that
in the final analysis ai is probably
more a than it is i
it's it's a little more artificial than
it is uh the the problems are
particularly artificial and the
solutions are not quite exactly uh what
i would call intelligent
they tend to be a little more a little
more linear
they at least don't analogize to
generalize intelligence in the way that
one would hope
uh so once again frustration it didn't
lead where i was uh
hoping it would but i decided to switch
my game up a bit i'd been
trying to find brilliant ideas and then
find people at stanford to help work on
them with me and i decided to invert the
model and try to find the brilliant
people
to work with and see what ideas they had
and so i went around and asked all my
friends
who were the most brilliant people they
knew and tried to meet them and asked
them the same question and
followed the trail of brilliant people
and there were a lot of
a lot of people pointing at this guy
peter thiel
as the smartest person they knew he
seemed to be at the top of the list
and so made it my goal to find this guy
and
talk to him and see what could get done
there
one of my good friends joe lonsdale who
i think just did an interview in the
daily
if uh any of you saw it he ended up
um we ended up co-founding palantir
together along with some other folks as
well
but he was working with peter at clarium
clarium was
peter's or is peter's global macro hedge
fund
he put it together right after he sold
paypal peter was uh
one of the founders and the ceo of
paypal before it was bought by ebay
and uh sure enough you know
peter was undoubtedly and still is the
highest iq guy i've ever met in my life
he's he's incredibly brilliant everyone
was right
uh but the thing that was striking this
is this is back in
2003 uh the paypal mafia still hadn't
started too many of its companies i mean
the paypal mafia as a term
wasn't even that well-known at the time
and this whole network they all had this
energy
and they were all putting together the
wisdom of how to actually
transcend that world of ideas and
punctuate the actual world and this
wisdom was being put together in ad hoc
fashion it's been formalized now more
through
these talks you can listen to max you
can listen to all of these guys talk
about their experiences and you can
learn a bit about that kind of grab bag
of tricks
but they were focused on the same
problem and they recognized it as the
problem it is
i think
i think you can define the smartest
um you could call it traditional or
standard iq
it's defined by what i would call a
competence
a clarity and then a gracefulness in the
execution when given a really tough
problem
uh whereas entrepreneurial talent or
entrepreneurial potential
it's almost always defined by being able
to summon
this incredible interpersonal intensity
and commitment to work on really hard
problems for
sometimes sustained amounts of time and
so when you see someone demonstrating
that
that's when you say that's going to be a
good co-founder and if they're brilliant
too well then hey you're really lucky
right you definitely want to work with
that person um
and so next thing i knew i was uh
interning at clarium 40 hours a week
i was trying to graduate early which i
don't know by some
uh some stroke of luck i actually
managed to uh to finish a few quarters
early here
and i was so i'm doing 40-hour job 20
units of cs
uh and you know everything else that we
all do here at stanford is undergrads
and the only way to make it work uh
quite frankly was to get in this habit
of
just blitzing three days in a row so for
one quarter that last quarter at
stanford with the exception of the first
and uh the last week of the quarter
tuesday through thursday i just wouldn't
sleep
i would literally just work i mean it
was wild and i couldn't even imagine
doing it now i mean now if
i don't get my eight hours of sleep i'm
quite a grumpy guy
but uh
uh anyways these these tuesdays through
thursdays
i would just you know around two or
three in the morning go down
el camino to uh the denny's it's no
longer there
uh it's now a su hong but i would go to
that denny's and
i would uh you know say hi to vladimir
he was the late night waiter we became
best friends
embarrassingly uh got to know each other
so well that he would just
let me go behind the uh the kitchen to
the back and get the food myself
which is quite something
but honestly it felt natural at the time
it didn't even feel
like that much of a push just it felt
like what needed to get done
and so i think it's critical while
you're here if you find opportunities to
engage
if you feel a resonance with an idea or
a project or a set of people
just run with that this this stuff is so
much of um
opening your mind and you know your
heart to the possibilities of doing it
of being that engaged with an idea
and even if it doesn't work then you
just gain so much from that experience
but so this this strategy of
focusing on finding the smartest people
and surrounding yourself with them
i want to caveat it uh with with
an important footnote here
i don't think a people first strategy in
isolation
ever really works i i don't think that's
successful and the
one of the core reasons is that you want
to surround yourself with brilliant
people but also people who are getting
stuff done and
doing interesting things but in general
those people
only got that way because uh they love
doing interesting things and they've
learned from those experiences and
they've changed them
so if you kind of do this like if you
take this pro networking argument to an
extreme of just trying to find the
brilliant people
if you're lucky you'll actually you know
get in front of them you'll
talk to them but when you're there
you're not going to have anything
substantive to discuss
you're not going to be in the world of
ideas the same way that you would be if
you really cared about them and focused
on the substance first
and so your best case scenario is kind
of having a shallow interaction with
them where
nothing um nothing truly substantive can
come about from it
but if on the other hand you care and
you're deeply passionate about these
ideas about the products about the
things that
can change the world and then you also
focus on finding the brilliant people
who want to
work in those spheres i think this is
really the right recipe
and this was essentially the
recipe that led to uh led to the early
days of palantir
so when peter finally uh
sat down and i guess this was like
midway in 2004
and said uh i've got this idea stefan
let's take some of the ideas from the
paypal defraud platform
and let's try to generalize them to
solve the country's counter-terrorism
problem
and we'll start by selling it directly
to the us government
and while we're at it let's solve the
generalized enterprise information
management platforms that are out there
let's help big enterprises use a silicon
valley approach to
understanding their data
in this kind of context of being around
these these brilliant folks but also
deeply caring for the ideas and the
products
this was this was obviously a winner
this is what i had been looking for that
that whole time at stanford and so it
was always right next to the stanford
institution but never quite linearly
connected
um yeah so away we went
away we went uh those staying up
you know tuesday through thursday uh
pushing and pushing i went from my
last cs final which i totally bombed i
think i got a
c minus or something for the first time
in that class i went from that last
final to
a little office uh 3000 sandhill where
peter had actually started paypal
and that was the first day of anyone
working full-time on palantir
we had very little time only about eight
weeks before a
killer meeting with a guy named gilman
louis who was uh
at the time the president of inquitel
inquitel
for those who haven't heard of it is the
intelligence community's
venture capital fund and they they do a
great job opening doors for
companies in silicon valley and
elsewhere that uh
want to work on the us government's
challenges so we have this
this meeting it's only two months away
and uh
you know we don't exactly have too much
product at the time
so it was prototype crunch time about
eight weeks through together
basic prototype i'd have to say uh
cs people in the room can understand
this it would be a little admittedly
uh was a little admittedly light on the
back end elements the initial prototype
a little more focused on the lights and
the fireworks and the
the front end but it uh it was a success
and gilman um gilman liked it and he
began to open the doors
for us uh in the us government but
before he left that meeting you said the
the most funny thing which was if you
guys can't
help us fix our uh counter-terrorism
problem you've got a bright future in
video games
so i took that as a ringing endorsement
uh i mean i'll share a few funny stories
from those times a few illuminating ones
you know there there we were crunching
away and
we were every
every other week basically flying out to
washington dc trying to meet with folks
inside uh
inside the government get as close to
our potential customers as possible
and just showing them uh our platform
showing them the prototype
and asking them you know what do you
want what do you need but the real
information uh
came from looking at the points of
resonance with the platform getting them
in front of it and seeing what they used
what did they like what were their eyes
attracted to what was what was actually
going on
um where were the real uh opportunities
to
to add value there um
and so uh we would go out there we would
gather this feedback and um we would
then uh
drink a whole bunch of these things and
crunch and get it integrated and do it
again and i i
the one of the one of the kind of points
that i think demarcated an element of
success was when my government sponsor
uh was introducing me at one of these
meetings and he said everyone i want to
introduce you
uh to mr two weeks he can he can build
anything you ever want in two weeks
so ask away um
and uh yeah needless to say again it's
another one of those
that's what you want to hear it's it's
uh what peter would say is the right
kind of problems to have
but it was it was definitely uh
definitely increased my red bull
consumption
um
and so in this process of fleshing out
the product
and finding the exact market fit finding
finding exactly how these pieces fit
together to fulfill that vision that
peter had originally outlined
um you know there's there's no
there's there's not really any uh easy
path through and there's not really any
linear path through it's the same thing
where you throw the entrepreneurial
intensity at it and then you kind of see
what sticks
but you can look and i think it's very
important to look for the demarcation
points that actually indicate
you are succeeding and so i the final
demarcation point where i would say
palantir went from more of a provisional
idea
to a full conviction for me personally
when i knew that
we really had an opportunity to change
things and impact the world it was
uh one of these meetings uh you know
get the mr two-week introduction and it
was a conference room with maybe 30
people in it
and these are all government folks all
in suits
government meetings are not uh not
terribly exciting
they they tend to go quite a slow pace
but this one this one was more exciting
people were were
energetic and they were really excited
with what we had and they could see the
disruption
at the end there was a moment where uh
you know the meeting was breaking
everyone was walking away and out of the
corner of my eye i see at the other end
of the room
two um two senior government executives
you know fully in their suits and
whatnot grown grown men who've been
in government service for over 20 years
stand up and give each other high fives
so when your government guys are doing
the high fives with each other
saying to themselves like how this is
going to change things you know that's
that's when you've done it that's when
and and i mean not done it but you're in
the position to do it
that's when i knew that if we could just
follow through with this if we can make
it work we could really really change
things and that that moment of founder
conviction
um that that i that uh it was a very
important moment
uh roughly around that time too are the
conceptual vision for the product
stabilized
and uh those are the moments where you
start to gain clarity on kind of what
the heart and soul is of what you're
doing
and for palantir what with the
fundamental aspiration of the platform
is it's basically to enable humans to
perform the analytical reasoning
that for whatever reason machines can't
seem to replicate
there's a certain form we could say uh
the the kind of simplistic version of
this is to enable the ideal human
computer
symbiosis but i think that doesn't quite
do justice to some of the more subtle
aspects of this the the idea here which
is firstly
um accepting as computer scientists and
engineers and just
people who are in the technology
business that there's actually a lot
computers can't do
uh there it could be for practical
empirical reasons could be for
theoretical reasons i find the
theoretical
possibilities quite interesting
themselves but accepting that
there's these these realms of uh
reasoning that computers are
particularly bad at without human help
like for instance figuring out what the
right framing is for a problem
you can't even really describe a problem
to a computer without a framing on it
that pre-exists
so you certainly can't hope for the
computer just to kind of tell you hey
here's the right framing
um computers are very bad at finding
patterns in data
unless there's an incredibly uh
dictionary long instance of a very well
constrained well understood problem then
it can begin to find certain patterns
and for the vast majority of human
analytical problems is just not it
it's sparse it's isolated things are
connected in ways we can
uh we have a stronger intuition for them
we have a rational reason
and so because of all these facts uh
really the right kind of future economic
relationship
for man and machine is one that deeply
respects the capabilities of what only
man can do
or just at least for now what only man
can do
and um also of course you know you want
this to be the computer scientists who
are recognizing this the machines can do
the absolute best of what they can do
the algorithmic reasoning right the um
the computational machinery that they
they the computational processes that
they can execute
trillions of times faster than we can
and so
this is this is the pound to your idea
um the ultimate pound to your aspiration
but i think that this idea is actually
just one part of a much broader
opportunity i wanted to talk about here
before we
open this thing up to questions and that
opportunity
well i'll sketch an image so take
the entire domain of human economic
activity
take all the things we do all the things
we want to do all the things that make
that up
and now draw a line that divides
on one hand the precisely definable
and on the other hand everything that's
not quite that
all the related phenomenon that for
whatever reason can't
quite be precisely pinned down so you
know
we can probably precisely pin down yes
or no am i hungry
but we can't precisely pin down you know
how hungry am i
what does that feel like we can assign a
number we can make an approximation
but that is a phenomenon is at best
exactly that an approximation
the fundamental fact of it is it exists
in something that's
uh much less precise but just as real
and just as tangible
i think that that line that separates
that precisely definable from that which
is not this is basically the line where
algorithms can uh might
let me let me backtrack for a second
this
may just be obvious from like a
technology entrepreneur's
standpoint but but i'll say verbatim i
really believe that with all the
advances we've had in computing
computers will do all things computers
can possibly do
so when it comes to uh
if you accept the kind of the the
extrapolation there
then the next question naturally becomes
what can computers do
if the answer is everything then we can
expect computers to be coming and
taking away a lot of what we do
day-to-day but i strongly believe it's
just not
actually there's a lot that computers
really can't do and i there's
also i'm very interested in the reasons
why quantum computing
i hope we don't have any administrators
in here but i spent last quarter
sneaking into the history corner
tuesdays and thursdays auditing the
quantum computing course that stanford
just started
uh teaching because it's it's deeply
fascinating stuff and
uh potentially in quantum computing
there are some answers to
why classical computational algorithms
might not be able to get
certain human reasoning tasks done but
nonetheless recognizing the depth and
the subtlety of the qualitative domain
and recognizing it as disjoint and
separate from the quantitative domain
this lets you start seeing problems a
little differently
there's a lot of interest in salesforce
other crm products
a lot web analytics and these are all
essentially domains where we are
collecting
we're building a quantitative universe i
mean the space of all big data is one
where we build a quantitative universe
and then we study it and one approach to
this is to say
let's get as much data as possible and
then let's develop the most
sophisticated algorithms possible for
finding patterns in the sea of
quantitative
quantitative data but i ultimately
don't believe that will be terribly
successful i think the
much more important questions are let's
study the
human aspects of this the qualitative
aspects the problem what are we trying
to get done
what's actually happening what are the
subtle aspects of this process that
when we actually clarify then we can
actually learn that's where we want to
collect the data that's what we want to
analyze that's what we want to figure
out
and through the study of the qualitative
phenomenon that dovetails right next to
this quantitative phenomenon in the
actual universe
through through this we can then
optimize how we use our computers
to uh actually do what we want them to
do and this
this place this is where i think we're
going to see a lot of technology
companies in the 21st century
i think this is much closer to the
actual 21st century
big data analysis problem um
at least much more so than getting uh
more and more fancy algorithms
to kind of do the same problems we've
already seen so
yeah with that i will turn it over to
you all for some questions
oh yeah yeah
how does this insight of use apply to
natural language
the natural language processing via
computing
how does this perspective shine on that
yeah so the question is how uh does this
perspective kind of shine on the natural
language processing problem
um that's a great question
so the i mean immediate thing is that
uh you probably don't want nlp
the stuff you do like good nlp will
probably be a lot like google
where it's disconnected from um
the intentional aspect the actual direct
value creation aspect that uh
you know us humans are actually focused
on it will probably remain more of a
tool
than um kind of a full turnkey technique
unless less uh
bullish on translation technology that
can capture all the subtlety and
complexity of grammatical constructs and
believe that that all that will kind of
converge at this natural
translation of meaning then more of kind
of the brute force stuff like
we'll do a lot of synonyms for some
phrases and then hopefully the other
smart human mind can put together the
rest of the context
i think the latter is where we'll see
mostly advances
but um but yeah it's a question worth
studying
so you said there was a line dividing
the domain of quantitative and
qualitative
things an algorithm can approach um so
does that intrinsically mean that
the line itself where you draw it is a
qualitative line
and if so uh redefining the quality of
problems to make them quantitative
problems can you apply an algorithm
there to do that yeah this is this is a
great question and and
you've uh you've picked up on the
subtlety and this uh
this explanation that uh at least the
computer scientists in the rooms will
probably find
uh very displeasing uh distasteful i
have a hard time with this idea
unto itself because of exactly this the
problem with
uh yeah so the the question was
kind of in a nutshell the line that
divides quantitative phenomenon from
qualitative phenomenon
uh must it be doesn't it inherently have
to be a qualitative line
and then kind of further is there a hope
of developing algorithms that could
perhaps figure out where this line is or
maybe pull some of the qualitative
problems into the quantitative domain
uh you know i think the line's
constantly moving i think it's fuzzy and
whatnot
but the the logical issue here that that
your you
highlight is that uh i'm defining
qualitative
negatively not positively because if we
could define qualitative phenomenon
in a very tight precise description then
of course we could just turn into a
quantitative phenomenon and we can use a
computer to solve it
and so it's one of these things it's uh
you know touches a bit i've warned you
all i was a sleek hit here before i
started talking so you you could hear a
little bit of a
sleep a little mark man call suzanne
here but um
uh in essence there are these kind of
ambiguous aspects to a lot of these
these human phenomena we experience
all the time including subjective
phenomena that
because they defy that precise logical
description we cannot turn them into
algorithms
and and i don't see that phenomenon is
is
being fundamentally tackled um by the
by these quantitative approaches but we
can definitely chip away at it
so yeah it's uh the real invitation here
with this
with this framing is to look at problems
to dive into those qualitative subtle
aspects
i was talking about going back and forth
to dc working on developing our product
and you know
there's all these kind of product
development formalisms you know
agile uh you've guys have probably
studied a whole bunch of them in some
msne courses here
but the the kind of framing
i had just reflecting on that problem is
there's a lot of really deep subtle
stuff the users ultimately don't know
what the product is they want i mean how
could they that's why you're the
entrepreneur
if they knew they would just make it
themselves they wouldn't they wouldn't
really need you
um and the only way you actually seek
satisfactory answers these questions of
what's the right product
what's the right feature is to look at
these subtle aspects and study them in
their own right
and really appreciate the depth of them
as a phenomenon unto themselves
not just kind of crassly reify them into
a logical conception that resembles a
much more quantitative friendly uh
truism
if that makes sense
who else so
there's a there's a lot of literature
recently about
left brain and right brain and who's
gonna what's
what should you be teaching your
children to do right so should you be
focused on
quantitative computational or creativity
and not necessarily to say those are
separate but i'm using shorthand here so
thinking about volunteering what you do
you're using computers to surface things
for people
so that people can do what they do best
is there a best background for the
person who's the
who's the best user of your app and
what kind of background do they have
yeah that's a great question
that's a great question uh to
some sum it up it's kind of reflecting
on this qualitative quantitative thesis
what makes the best user for palantir
how does that relate to it
so the strongest strongest users we've
had they actually have some of those
entrepreneurial qualities
they really want to get things done they
want in in their enterprise they care
deeply about
solving the actual problem uh
accomplishing the mission
so they have that entrepreneurial
quality and they almost always
categorically have a
another feature which is they're
incredibly frustrated
with the organization's uh kind of
existing technology base
the inability to use all these wonderful
quantitative tools to actually impact
the mission
um so starting from that base of
frustration uh
and deep concern for the mission um
they they see palantir as uh
a lens through which they can they can
better understand what's actually
happening
in their organization what's happening
in the ground reality it's
at at the end of the day a lot of um
they're they're essentially respecting
the deep and complex subtleties that are
actually out there in the real world
but then by appreciating those
complexities able to map a lot of that
information back into palantir
and then take advantage of our
facilities to enable collective
um collective learning collective
pursuit of the uh the
objective there but so the relation i
don't know if i can break it down into
uh what classes people should take or
what what folks should study
um and i i would wouldn't dare jump into
that debate anyways but uh in essence i
would say it's a deep appreciation for
the complexities and subtleties of the
ground reality
but then also just a deep desire to get
leverage on it
collectively as an institution by
pulling it into palantir being able to
model it
in an in an accurate way and something
that does justice to those underlying
truths
one question for professor cosmic and
one for myself so the first
is he told me that you introduced up to
50 people a day
would you guys are expanding a week a
week okay yeah
i have my executive assistant here who's
going to test the scheduling uh
nightmare here we talked about how it is
really important to find those
interesting people is what do you look
for those interviews or
how do you know that yes this is someone
that's going to be able to work for you
that's the first question
the second question is you had all these
different ideas that you're really
passionate about
how did you find which ones to focus on
which ones to spend those times going
you know around with a cart and
stanford's
another idea i think you have to push a
lot of carts around stanford before you
come up with the right idea so uh
you know definitely keep your eye on the
zany person with something not working
they may be coming up with something
that will work
a bit later um
yeah so the first question what do we
look for palantir
um what's going on these interviews uh
so i i like to try to meet every single
person we hire um
uh perform the last last interview in in
the palantir process um
sometimes earlier interviews and the
there
there's a lot of subtlety and complexity
to it too so i don't want to pretend to
break it down into a basic rubric or
anything else it won't do justice to it
but the uh the essential qualities
that we look for even though they come
in many different uh
various forms of different people in
different positions in the company
is the highest concentration of talent
possible
that's that's number one number two uh
long-term time horizons
and number three um what i like to call
generative personalities
so i'll break those down talent as i was
mentioning before
um i think talent can really be
identified by
uh firstly like a competence in solving
whatever problems that you know town is
kind of directed at uh
and then in the kind of competent uh
problem solving and
in the competent uh execution looking
for answers
there's actually just a deep
gracefulness so it's not just
that the person knows how to answer the
question it's that they're even graceful
in their process of answering it
this almost always means they add
clarity right they they clarify the
problem structure and the solution
structure
so uh i mean in kind of algorithms
problems and whatnot this is
at least easier i think to identify
because the problems are much more well
constrained
but they're very hard so the people who
are able to uh
confidently answer the question clarify
the basic construct of the problem and
then uh
even executed in graceful way those are
always the most talented
uh but it applies just as much so to
domains outside of computer science
you know in um in sales context in
engineering contexts
uh you want a good salesperson to be
able to clarify what the actual problem
was
what was the tactical ground reality how
did they proceed through it
how did they what were they trying to
accomplish and how did they do what did
they do right what they do wrong
this is what you want in the talent side
second thing is long-term time horizons
this one's critical and it's it's
another one that you know no one hit me
over the head with when
when i was here uh when you have that
talent it's very hard
to create a substantial store of value
unless you really want to work on the
same thing unless you really are willing
to to dedicate your talent
to kind of focus it through some
duration of time on a particular task
and what uh we'll find out there is
it's in many ways kind of a
self-directed construct how you how you
look at the world whether or not you
focus on
a handful of problems and derive your
satisfaction from solving them
longitudinally versus if you're kind of
always jumping from one thing to a next
and you actually don't like to stick
with anything for the long term
and this is i don't mean for this to
suggest that like just do one thing
and don't vary it like if anything you
just heard from this talk i was doing a
hundred different things
but you you can see there's still some
common threads to it and that
commonality that's the long term time
piece
that's that's kind of that's what we
look for at palantir and the third and
last
trait is the generative personality and
this is uh
you can be very talented you can have
very long-term time horizons
but um some of you might even have a
professor that does this
they they apply the talent that
long-term time horizon
to um kind of showing why a lot of ideas
don't work or why they're silly
and they're more hesitant to um
construct and be generative about
proposing solutions
and uh it's it's very important i think
in any startup to generate as much
momentum as possible
and so that means you you want to take
that talent that long-term time horizon
and focus it
in the most kind of creative energetic
way possible
does that make sense yeah that's what we
look for
how do you uh how do you bridge that gap
between the engineering
gracefulness of design and thinking and
execution
with the sales side and having clarity
of
of uh i guess communication the intent
and purpose of your
solution to a client base that's maybe
not quite as aware as they could be
can you see that can you repeat that one
more time how do you bridge between
engineering and sales so that you've got
that gracefulness that comes out and
your salespeople when they're speaking
to your clients
oh yeah no this is this is a a very good
question
basically how do we reconcile the
engineer and the engineering aspects of
the sales aspects especially
hopefully in a way that uh constitutes
some gracefulness of execution
and i would say the first thing is we
probably focus a little less on the
gracefulness of execution and more on
this kind of substance forward
perspective we like to get the engineers
and people actually add value as close
to the front lines as possible
interacting with the clients
it's basically we want to
we want to share as much of our
fundamental substance with each and
every party we work with as possible
probably have time for one more here
yeah go ahead uh i know
you obviously mentioned uh your
platform's being used by the us
government
in terms of counterterrorism operations
but is volunteer considered
marketing its product to other countries
who are dealing with domestic armed
conflict
um and if so are there any sort of legal
ramifications to that
uh in terms of is even violating
international law i think
if your technology is hiding
counterterrorism or terrorism operations
in places
that's being called into question does
palantir have any probability in that
or no i mean i i don't uh
counterterrorism was an initial
impetus for the company but it's a very
very small aspect of what we do these
days and uh with the principal customer
being the us government
um you know there's there's not uh
there's not um unlimited leeway in other
parties you work with and there's
there's a lot of scrutiny
and we just as founders care about it
very very deeply
so um although there's there's always
legal aspects
uh you get good lawyers they help you
out with these things what really
matters more i think are the the moral
aspects the mission and the purpose and
we focus the most on that and making
sure that we're having a positive impact
all right well
uh you know i'm going to leave that time
for you all to come up here and
address questions individually but thank
you very much